we were about to show it to the viewers  I think dukesh has  beaten Hare Krishna oh already  yeah  yeah I mean this is just a full piece I  don't know where it went like the last  time I looked black had the full  complement of pieces  but now one is gone  in this game so I'm I'm gonna let's take  a look in lightning fashion this isn't  worth a Savage slav yeah uh which is  more Savage love oh okay I thought it  was over elegant well yes but G5  specifically I think is okay  I I I understand your point but I think  this this specific subline is I just  went 95 here and I got taken yeah okay  okay that's unfortunate I guess he maybe  did not have really have a better move  anymore I think maybe the previous movie  of GGA maybe was  uh not best but but looks like black  isn't